how much music are you releasing this
year just I mean we got the new project
February 10th yeah that that table has
closed room
are you are you like spinning the block
pretty soon are you gonna let it live
for a while what are you doing I mean
like
I'm gonna let that [ __ ] marinate because
they all hits like I did songs with mad
people right
foreign
[Music]
who do you got is the greatest I mean
you from a very legendary Borough it's
literally where hip-hop started the
birthplace of hip-hop it's the Bronx
who's in your top five Bronx MCS of all
time you can't say yourself you can't
say yourself say MCS like yeah rap can't
even think of rappers from the rooms
that's who old Big Pun fat Fat Joe I
could say a fat Joe Big Pun who I'm
gonna say
like yo Max who we who from the Bronx
was rapping back then I don't know this
ever because I was listening to 50 like
that's Queens like I'm gonna be able I'm
gonna give it a bug like I'm from the
bunks but when I was growing up I'm
listening to 50
I'm listening to [ __ ]
fabulous Jay-Z lots of Brooklyn and
Queens Brooklyn Queens like you for me
of course Fat Joe yeah
shout out to Joey crap who Joey crack
they call him Joey crack Joey correct
man I mean listen Fat Joe instrumental
that's why I did the weed challenge too
bro I went made a challenge to his
instrumental he I know you see that
yeah have you met him yet you guys both
are on Empire
[Music]
um
everybody I don't know if I see them
I'll probably yo he came to my hood
though
he came in my hood hey I came to your
hood yeah you came here You Came To My
Hood got a chopped cheese I ain't gonna
lie but he came out Hood he did like a I
think he was like yo yo man we can't
can't call out you remember
yo when we were hanging out in your area
we were just like hanging out in some
random Courtyard yeah for like houses
only two hours and I was like my boy's
from the Bronx and I dropped at my
location he's like bro you are in the
middle of the [ __ ] over there
oh yeah he was in the defenses I ain't
gonna lie to you bro it was cool though
we was flying the Drone around that
[ __ ]
cardi B's up there too best Bronx
rappers right I mean she's been putting
on for sure yeah cardi B you got ice
spice ice ice spices from the Bronx from
the boss I'm not sure we could put her
any best rapper discussion she's a
rapper though Naya she's doing her thing
though she's doing her thing
there's mad new people right now
coming from the bones
yeah you know what that is yeah yeah
he's on fire he's on fire yeah you're on
fire right now I didn't even know he's
from the Bronx I just know thank you for
the bones he's selling out hell no you
know I don't think from the bones he's
like a kid too right yeah
yeah you guys are killing it man
huh
oh KRS one of course KRS one wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait Ron you don't know who cares
one of the greatest rappers of all time
now in fact shout out to kills one I was
listening to two people never in your
[ __ ] life listen to KRS one that's
how I do not one [ __ ] Aretha Franklin
you Martha Stewart doesn't make music
Ron who mother she's a she cooks on TV
and steals money
she's on TV with Snoop that's my stuff
one song you've ever listened to in your
life
[Laughter]
you told me they were so like I know
that I named the song for you I know
that song
like what other song they made like it
was in movies though if it was the South
Bronx the South South Bronx I know that
song
that stone that's boogie down
Productions that's KRS one yo they beef
up you don't even know
the [ __ ] that made on hip hop for the
Bronx you know how he had a crates yeah
my dad was holding trees he was holding
the crates at that time when hip hop he
was freestyling back then when like
hip-hop was invented your dad was there
the apostles did are you telling me your
dad invented hip-hop he was in that
generation he was he was I'm influenced
by hip-hop so your dad was there with
like cool herc and all that [ __ ] but
that was holding it back yo I go out on
my daughter look on my daughter neck I
said [ __ ] Cedar oh my go to the neck
my dad was he knew who hurted wow they
knew each other well look at you you're
[ __ ] hey he lived on that block you
were born for this [ __ ] my dad lived on
that block when he was younger
I swear to God and I was born I don't
believe you've ever listened to KRS but
I believe this my pop was in the crib
freestyling
freestyle that I'm already rapping wow
I'm trying to show you I'm trying to
show you bro